all right.
Let's get into audience questions for the
week.
We missed audience questions last week because
I was traveling back and forth to La in the
middle of the week.
That led to us doing a sort of different Friday
show where I didn't take audience questions,
but we're doing it this week.
The first one's from devel s devel says, Hey
David, do you think Joe Biden strategy of
limited exposure, we'll help him or hurt him
at the end?
Or do you think there's another reason for
it?
Such as not having the energy and stamina
to campaign around the country?
I've seen no evidence that there's an energy
or stamina issue with Joe Biden.
Um, I think that it is a calculated decision
that his team made, although I would argue
incorrectly, uh, to sort of limit his exposure
until the debates start.
Presumably also doing debate prep to be as
best prepared as possible for the debates
that are scheduled to start in a, at this
point, it's just a couple of weeks.
I think that in the immediate, uh, it did
sort of a work in the sense that before his
announcement, Joe Biden was pulling in the
low to mid twenties and after his announcement,
Joe Biden started pulling as high as 40 or
41% in some democratic primary polls.
But that has trailed off and Joe Biden has
dropped into the mid to low thirties.
In most recent polls, as Bernie Sanders has
regained momentum, I know there are people
who will straight up say, David, the Polzer
totally fake and concocted.
And of course, uh, if that's the case, give
me some evidence of that.
If we accept that the polls are at least generally
right in terms of the momentum of the race
in terms of who's on the upswing or the downswing,
what we've seen is that recently Biden has
started to trail off from his post announcement.
Hi.
Whereas Bernie Sanders, uh, Pete Buddha judge
has been on the rise lately.
Elizabeth Warren has seen a slight uptick,
uh, in, in the most recent couple of weeks.
I don't think there is any reason to think
that the limited exposure strategy for Joe
Biden has worked.
Ultimately, what this is going to come down
to is what happens once the debates get going.
I've said before that Joe Biden is a very
good skilled debater when it comes to one
on one debates against Republicans.
If you look at what Joe Biden did with Paul
Ryan, uh, during that vice presidential debate
some years ago, he mopped the floor with Paul
Ryan.
I mean, it was an embarrassing, embarrassing
experience for Paul Ryan and Joe Biden did
extraordinarily well.
I am less confident and Joe Biden's skills
in a larger debate against other Democrats,
particularly when we know that Joe Biden is
a center left candidate.
He is not the most progressive candidate or
anything close to it.
And right now there is a hankering among the
democratic, uh, the, among the Democratic
Party.
Yeah.
Uh, for a more progressive alternative to
republicanism and two establishment centrist
Democrats.
So, uh, although I have full confidence that
if I'm Joe Biden is the nominee, he will do
really well into the debates against Donald
Trump.
This doesn't mean Joe Biden's politics or
my politics.
I am well to the left of Joe Biden.
I'm analyzing what will happen when the debate
start.
I think Biden would do really well against
Trump.
I am not super confident and Joe Biden's ability
to do a really good job against other Democrats,
particularly other Democrats that are too.
Joe Biden's left, so we will see in the end
what happens with Joe Biden's strategy.
There is no question that once the debates
start, Joe Biden's low exposure strategy is
going to have to end if he wants to maintain
the lead that he has in the Democratic primary
period because other candidates that are doing
everything from numerous town halls, including
in red parts of the country like Elizabeth
Warren to a Fox News town hall like Bernie
Sanders to all sorts of different shows ranging
from Bill Maher to the breakfast club like
is Andrew Yang.
Even though his polling numbers aren't great,
I don't see how Joe Biden sticks it out till
the end with the limited exposure strategy,
but we'll see if it pays dividends for him
in terms of allowing debate prep between now
and the start of the democratic debates.